I remember being in New York and uh like
it was with Warner Music Group during
the litigation and we spent the whole
day getting negotiating and they were
like, "Hey, you want to go to the Knicks
game the night and so I went to the
Knicks game with the suing you?"
>> I don't think they thought it was a big
deal. That's how normal that's they were
just so used to suing people. They're
like, "Oh, you're a good guy. Let's go
see the Knicks."
Hello Lou. All right. All right. Hello.
our advice on lawsuits and regulation
and dealing with the government. I think
we've got decent credentials on this
subject. Yeah, you got to tell them what
our credentials are. Yeah. Why Why don't
you start? What are your lawsuit
credentials? My first company that I
started in 2003 was called IEM and it
was a music streaming site and it um
and many of my early employees formerly
worked at a company called Napster and
um not kidding. And there was a lot of
overlap with the DNA. It was like the
thing after Napster and needless to say
we eventually got deals with the music
industry and that's a whole long story
but in the process we definitely were in
a lot of litigation and so a lot of my
life for a couple years as a startup
founder was uh dealing with that stuff
and so sadly I have credentials here. I
represented the other end of the
spectrum.
So, I worked in a company called Twitch,
and when it started, it was called
Justin TV. And I remember this moment
where someone in Ohio decided to stream
the Super Bowl live on our website. And
I remember watching that part in the
beginning that says like, "This can't be
rebroadcasted, retransmitted." And I'm
like watching this on my own website and
I was like, "Huh?" Um, Michael, to be
honest, I I definitely at least once
watched the Super Bowl on your website.
We were pitching a VC and he's like,
"Oh, I wanted to go to the Masters." And
I was like, "You can just watch it on
our website, did not invest." So, in the
process, we got sued by the UFC, NBC.
And then we got called in front of
Congress to testify about sports piracy
by the major Major League Baseball. It
was you. You had to go in front of
Congress and talk about piracy.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, man.
I think maybe what I would start with is
what was your experience of being sued
in kind of the speed of startups versus
the speed of lawsuits. The way I would
frame this as it pertains to current
modern startup advice is the following.
New technologies
often are encumbered for better or worse
by laws that were created way before the
technologies existed. And so dealing
with copyright law, there's all this
stuff about mechanical reproduction,
which was the physical reproduction of
records. And that's codified in the law.
And I I became an expert on this stuff.
And trying to translate law that was
about physical media to digital media
was like totally
dumb. I I don't know. I can use other
more colorful terms, but it it it was
really hard. And the way I think this is
relevant to right now is the attempts to
regulate AI. In addition, a lot of our
startups, our portfolio companies
have experienced tremendous change in
the regulatory environment over the past
few years. Fortunes are being made and
lost based on what kind of laws are
being passed and the sophistication
ability for founders to navigate these
things. Um, just to throw out a couple
of of examples here. Um, anyone here
hearshi? You know the company? A few
people. So, look, they're they're doing
extremely well. Michael funded them for
YC. That's his company. You're on the
board or something, right? Michael's on
the board of that company. And they
basically spent years suing the
government. Why don't you tell them? Why
don't you tell them about They only
started suing the government recently.
>> I think this is one of the only
companies I've ever worked with that is
so regulated that they had to have a
government strategy pre-product and they
basically had to get licensed before
they could do anything.
counterintuitively funding two MIT CS
kids right out of college where the
first thing they have to do is get a
license from some CFTC.
>> So they chose to be regulated by CFTC,
right? That was a they chose not to go
to jail immediately.
The fun part of their story is they
tried to get a law firm to represent
them in applying for this license and no
law firm would work with them because
they were like you or two MIT kids who
are not qualified to do anything. And so
um similar to a lot of companies we
funded think about the Brexers, they're
like we're just going to read the law
and fill out the paperwork ourselves.
And in about a year and a half they got
their license. And then what was really
funny is like the law firms that
rejected them said um when your company
fails because it's never going to work.
Still, we'll hire you. And they're like,
"What do you mean?" Like we're not
lawyers. Like you're fine. Like we'll
just hire you. Like if you could do
this, the legal stuff is not a problem.
More recently during the last election,
they were prohibited from listing
elections on their prediction
marketplace. And so that's when they
sued the government.
>> I was in this great board meeting where
they're like, "We want to sue the
government." I was like,
I don't even know how to give you advice
on this. You know, government stuff, so
good luck. And then they emailed like
two months later like, we won. We get to
run elections. And I'm like, okay. And
then they did it again to be able to
have sports. And so, one of the very
very few cases where I've seen a startup
have an offensive legal strategy against
the government and uh it's one great.
Most of the time I think people just
kind of sulk in the background like us
or Airbnb or I think low sophistication
was more normal back then but the folks
that we're seeing that are good at this
are higher sophistication on their
strategy around this. Um one one of my
super recent things is did you guys see
the new bank that Palmer Lucky started
that got a denovo banking charter? So
the actual CEO of that is a guy I funded
at YC. This is his next startup. I can't
believe they did it. Again, I would
argue this is a different an example of
understanding the regulatory environment
and reacting to it quickly because the
idea of being able to get a new banking
charter to do crypto for all, you know,
crypto rails is totally nuts. Imagine
telling your lawyer that a few years ago
>> company that tried to get a banking
license and it took five years and they
had to buy a small bank like a physical
bank. And so, again, high sophistication
founders like the guy that I know that
the CEO of it, he was doing a heavily
regulated crypto thing before. And so
very high sophistication on this stuff.
And so I think that would generally be
the advice I would give to founders.
>> Would you go so far as to say whereas
historically we might have been a little
bit more afraid of companies attacking
regulation, now we might be more like,
hey, the government's open for business.
>> I think you want to watch out tying
yourself too much to anyone
administration. But in general, high
sophistication people taking high risk
is often a really good bet. The higher
the sophistication, the more you can
take very high risk.
>> So maybe let's switch topic. Where do we
see founders
maybe misunderstanding how to use
lawyers or misunderstanding how they get
value out of lawsuits?
>> Well, okay, there's a few things. Um,
number one, it is the job of someone in
that role to never be wrong. Um, I would
argue that malpractice is when they tell
you that's wrong, right? Therefore,
you are always going to get the most
cautious advice such that they can't be
disproven. And so often our advice to
founders on how to work with lawyers is
say what you want to accomplish first
versus asking can I do X. Do you see how
there's a difference? You want to say I
want to do X. What should I be thinking
about? Because the lawyer will close be
like no don't do it if you ask for
permission. So that was a $4 million
swing in my first company. we were
streaming video and we asked our lawyer,
"Can we run ads?" And he said,
"Absolutely not. That'd be a violation
of the DMCA.
We didn't know what that meant, but that
sounded really scary." And then I
remember we talked to our friends who
instead of stealing copyritten video,
they were stealing copyritten text books
and they were running tons of ads and
they were profitable. And we were like,
"What is going on?" And literally one of
the founders like, "Oh, just ask your
lawyers like how to do it." And then and
then we asked our lawyer like, "How do
we do this?" And the guy's like, "You
know, actually, now that I think about
it, if you're in trouble, monetizing
this content doesn't get you in that
much more trouble." So, go to town. And
we were like, "Wow, we clicked a button
and that year we made $4 million before
we made zero dollars." Of course, we did
get sued. So, but I think we would have
gotten sued regardless.
>> That is correct. Um I think num number
two
>> is like in a negotiation like we I'm
we're involved in lots of financings and
my in my current role I'm involved in
lots of financings and I have to coach
the founders which is to just tell their
lawyers hey uh we want to we want to do
this deal. Um
does that make sense? Because otherwise
they'll just like do lawyer stuff and
like oh here's my red lines. Um and you
like no like just please don't do that.
and they'll be like, "Okay,
there's an extension of this that
actually I remember we talked about,
Nicole and I talked about, which is like
your lawyer should know whether you're
in a high leverage or lowle leverage
negotiation."
And like it it's not something that
occurred to me. I was like, "Oh, isn't
this just like a machine that's like,
well, you know, if you have six term
sheets, there's certain things you can
ask for, and if you have one verbal,
there may be other things you can't."
And so I think that that was another
piece of advice I end up giving to a lot
of founders like clue your lawyers in on
how much leverage you have and you might
be surprised at the things that they say
you could ask for. And we see YC
companies get crazy things in
financings, right? Like absolutely not
things.
>> Yeah.
>> I think the other vector to think about
is understanding what are minor speed
bumps on the way to building a good
company versus existential issues. This
comes up a lot devising companies. So,
for instance, if you run certain types
of businesses, you're inevitably going
to get sued for stuff. Like if you're
running like a Door Dash, you know,
there's going to be some litigation and
um you just have to learn to not freak
out about it if you want to run that
kind of business. And there's some
things where if you if you run into
legal issues, it's a real problem and
you got to, you know, financial crime,
payroll. Yeah. You're going to go to
jail. And so I I would always try to
have founders get sophisticated around
understanding how common and how much
it's just part of business to deal with
certain types of legal friction versus
extremes. Um something that would happen
a lot is sometimes people would get
letters from their former employer that
were mad that they started a startup.
>> Yeah.
>> You do you guys know what I'm saying?
And so they would be like, "Oh my god,
like what's going to happen?" It's like
don't worry about it. Generally, they
were, you know, empty threats and
uninforceable non-compete kind of stuff.
And so, a lot of our job was to tell
people, don't worry about it. But
sometimes there were things like
financial crimes where we'd be like, you
should definitely look into this
immediately and drop everything. Yeah.
And I think founders don't know the
difference between those two things at
at the beginning.
>> Just to extend that, I think that one of
the things I realized working at so many
companies is how many bisdev steels
start with a CN D letter. a founder will
be like, "I'm under threat. Oh god, I
got to like put up the defenses." And
I'm like, "No, I think they just want to
talk to you." And the way they talk to
you, and it works like send you a CN D
letter. And it's like, it does get your
attention. And I I had did office hours
literally two days ago where, you know,
the guy was like, you know, BMW sent us
a CND letter and like our lawyers say we
can fight. And I'm like, first of all,
you're not going to beat BMW, but second
of all, don't you want them to be a
customer? And and he's like, "Yeah." And
I'm like, "Well, this is the Here you
go." And he's like, "But they sent us a
CN." And it's like, "No, they just want
to talk. It's just the beginning of the
relationship." Yeah, they just want to
talk. That's fine. Like they could have
just sent you a lawsuit. Like they send
you a letter is the least they could do.
And so I think that comes up so many
times like, "Oh god, we got this letter.
Aren't we fucked?" And no. One other
vector for this too that I sometimes
would say to people in office hours is
that a lot of startups their entire
reason for existence is to absorb risk
to absorb legal risk. Um so to go on a
path down memory lane so open AAI was
started as part of Y cominator. It was
called Y cominator research and we were
part of what that was at that stage in
time and the genesis by which it was
created this is all public information
was that um Ilia which is the researcher
who was doing all the good work wanted
to build stuff at Google and he was not
allowed because of lawyers and um I
actually interviewed him for the job of
co-founder of what became open AI
believe it or not and the entire reason
he left Google to build it was because
he wanted to get away from the lawyers
was a Google and when you think about
the ability to actually ship LLMs, you
needed to absorb a lot of risk to crawl.
Think about all the stuff they crawled
without permission. Think about the
stuff that they ship that you would
never be able to do in big big tech. And
so the entire industry basically only
existed because someone was willing to
absorb a great deal of legal risk that
their GC would have not allowed at a big
tech company. Now it is a big tech
company, hilariously. And so when you
think about it, I think a lot of
economic value is created by just
warehousing all the risk in these
entities
>> and like you know a lot of times it
doesn't work but often that's where most
of the value is created.
>> Well I think that's a perfect example
because I think the lawyers were right
in both cases.
>> Totally.
>> I think the lawyers at Google were
absolutely right saying we're if
you do what you're about to do.
>> It's true.
>> The lawyers at OpenAI were exactly right
saying well what's the worst they can do
to you? And I think that this is where
the founders have to understand
the riskreward ratio. How many founders
do you talk to? I talk to so many
founders that are making a couple
million in revenue and I swear they
sound like they're running public
companies with like shareholders and
with like a hostile board. They have
like, you know, projections down to the
quarter cent. And I'm like, you're on
the risk side. You're you're you're not
supposed to be safe. And they're like,
"Oh, aren't we going to win by being
safe?" I'm like, "Again,
if you look, what's the number one app
in the app store right now?" Anybody?
Sora.
Why is it the number one app in the app
store? Because you can make famous
people do embarrassing things. Um, they
are definitely violating all sorts of
name and likeness stuff and they're
going to lock it down, but that's why
that's popular. And I think you can view
a lot of innovation and technology as
basically wellthoughtout calculated
risks and being willing to deal with it.
Last thing I was point this was this was
the main reason um my recollection uh
from their investors of why YouTube sold
to Google is basically Google was
willing to deal with all the copyright
stuff as a standalone company. They
weren't able to absorb it. And again as
as humans, aren't you glad YouTube
exists like I am? Like it's a really
cool thing for the world. But the way
they got that from zero to one was to
absorb some risk, I think, is one way to
say it, right? And it's easy to forget
that that was the entire original usage
of the thing, just like your company.
You know, these days it's a whole
different medium than what they
bootstrapped it off of. Justin Bieber
was on today. It's funny because I was
having this conversation with somebody
who was like, you know, Airbnb screwed
up their whole like legal thing. And I
was like, it's an interesting
interpretation of what happened, right?
You know, certainly Airbnb's
relationships with cities could be
better, but like
on average, I would say that worked.
And I would say that like having the
insight that helping people in a city or
anywhere make money from their property
was probably
a good play and that the regulations
would probably end up changing or
allowing it if they helped enough
people. And I kind of feel like Uber was
saying it's like if we help enough
people the regulations can change. I
think so many times when I talk to
founders they assume that these laws are
like written like in the Bible and you
know judgment will be passed down in the
form of death and they don't realize
that it's just the guidelines we've all
come up with to try to explain how we
should deal with the world that used to
exist and like that's it. It's the best
we can do. There's no sacredness from
man-made laws. Um they're not sacred at
all. And um whereas as opposed to like
if your startup hurts people that's bad
like even if there's no law about it
like it's really bad. So I think I find
when founders are on the fence I often
ask them like are they making people's
lives better? Are they are they helping
people? And then I I'm way more push
them on the risk side. And like when
they're not helping people I'm like well
why are you even doing this? Like why
are we debating the law? Before we wrap
up do you have any funny lawsuit stories
you want to share? like stories that at
the time made you want to die, but in
hindsight over 10 years later, you can
laugh at. I remember being in New York
and uh like it was with Warner Music
Group during the litigation and we spent
the whole day negotiating and they're
like, "Hey, you want to go to the Knicks
game tonight?" And so I went to the
Knicks game with the
>> Well, they're suing you.
>> I don't think they thought it was a big
deal. That's how normal. That's They
were just so used to suing people.
They're like, "Oh, you're a good guy.
Let's go see the Knicks." How about you,
man? It was 20 days before the Beijing
Summer Olympics
and uh NBC had spent, don't quote me on
this, but I think it was like $9 billion
for the online streaming rights or
something. I got a phone call on a
Friday on my cell phone and this
extremely polite woman was like, "I'm
the outside counsel for NBC and we're
going to go to court on Monday and have
the judge shut your website down for the
entire time of the Olympics and I'm just
calling to let you know," which I think
is like, and it's super polite. It was
it was it was a great and to be honest,
I'm really happy she called.
And so, you know, we had copyrighting
site content on our site for a while and
we would have had the Olympics for sure.
I I remember being like one, no
copyright owner has ever asked us for
anything in this way. Like, this is a
very motivational ask. You know,
everyone's sending us letters. We're
ignoring that So, I said, "Hey, is
there anything we could do so you won't
shut our website down and kill our
company on Monday?"
And she's like, you know, I don't even
want to say it because you you couldn't
ever do anything like this over a
weekend. I was like, just try us.
She's like, well, if you built us a
whole separate website where we could
have our team of a hundred people who
are monitoring sites all over the
internet, have access to every one of
your live streams, and can one click
file a DMCA takedown, and in real time,
that stream would be taken over. And if
they could have usernames and passwords
and the legal team could get every
single one of those DMCA filings and if
you could have that by Sunday, we might
consider not shutting your website down
on Monday. And I was like, you know what
I thought? I was like, that's actually
not that hard.
>> It's way harder to stream all the
Olympics to the whole world than it is
to build that website. And so I said,
okay, what number can I call you on the
Sunday? And she gave me a phone number.
And then I went to the team who was like
getting ready to go into the weekend and
I was like, "Guess what we're gonna work
on?"
We built this whole thing for them. I
called her on Saturday and Sunday,
showed her how to use it. She never
called back. She never said, "We're not
going to sue you." She just kind of
ghosted me and we lived and it was
great.
>> Good work, Mike P.
>> Best lawyer I've ever interacted with.
With that, thank you so much. This was a
lot of fun. Thanks everybody.